I think why not both? You know, people should be experts in as many things as they can. You know, your brain is not a bucket to be filled where if you put too much things in, it pushes other things out. No, your brain is a tree where if you grow a new branch, you have more places to hang things. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 246, recorded on August 5th, 2025. My name is Connor, and today I get my co-host, Ben's thoughts on AI. I'm curious to get your thoughts on AI.
我觉得为什么不能两者兼得呢？你知道，人们应该尽可能多地成为各个领域的专家。你的大脑不是一个用来填满的桶，如果装得太满，就会把别的东西挤出去。不，你的大脑是一棵树，如果你长出一根新树枝，你就有更多的地方可以挂东西。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 246 期，录制于 2025 年 8 月 5 日。我是 Connor，今天我请到了我的联合主持人 Ben，来谈谈他对人工智能的看法。我很想听听你对人工智能的看法。
coding tools. I'm not sure if you listened or skipped to the Bryce episodes. I did. I did listen to those last couple of episodes. I'm not an adherent of AI assisted coding tools. I want to work on things that AI can't do, frankly. And I don't think, I'm wondering whether AI is good for the world. You know, it doesn't seem to be doing much good for the world. This is important, right? It is important. So either, you know, either I'm going to come across as an old fuddy-duddy and you can reject what I say, or I'm going to come across as someone wise and you can listen to what I say. Either way, I have opinions.
编码工具。我不确定你有没有听过或者跳过了 Bryce 的那几期。我听了，我确实听了最后那几期。我不是 AI 辅助编码工具的拥护者。坦白说，我想做的是 AI 做不到的事情。而且我不认为，我在怀疑 AI 对这个世界是否有益。你知道，它似乎并没有给世界带来多少好处。这很重要，对吧？确实很重要。所以，要么我会显得像个老古板，你可以拒绝我的观点；要么我会显得像个智者，你可以听听我的想法。无论如何，我都有自己的看法。
Well, I would like to hear your opinions, and I'm sure the listener, I mean, there was, I think it is the Stack Overflow survey, which admittedly now that I think about it, I forgot had come out, but I heard about it on a Python podcast. and the reason I'm bringing up now is they asked a bunch of AI tooling and AI questions and one of them was like what's your general experience and I think it was 67 or 70% of folks said they were frustrated by them where they felt like they weren't meeting their needs for what they were doing so I think that potentially Bryce and I are in the minority and actually most of folks at least according to the Stack Overflow survey are not on the hype train and so anyway
嗯，我很想听听你的看法，我相信听众也是。我想起来了，Stack Overflow 的调查报告，虽然我现在才想起来，但我之前在 Python 播客上听到过。我之所以现在提出来，是因为他们问了一堆关于 AI 工具和 AI 的问题，其中一个问题是关于你的总体体验。我想大概有 67% 或 70% 的人表示对它们感到沮丧，因为他们觉得这些工具无法满足他们的需求。所以我认为，我和 Bryce 可能属于少数派，实际上大多数人，至少根据 Stack Overflow 的调查，并没有盲目跟风。所以，总之
over to you I'm happy to hear your opinions and I'm sure everyone else is a well. Yeah, I think, well, I don't know about that. Well, I think one thing we can say is that from that survey, the average working developer has less trust in AI this year than they did last year. That was one of the data points I think came out of that survey. Am I remembering that right? Well, I haven't read the survey, so we'll take your word for it.
交给你了，我很乐意听听你的看法，我相信其他人也是。是的，我想，嗯，我不知道该怎么说。但我认为有一点我们可以肯定，从那份调查来看，普通在职开发者今年对 AI 的信任度比去年要低。这是我认为那份调查得出的数据点之一。我没记错吧？嗯，我没读过那份调查，所以我们就听你的吧。
I think one of the points was, you know, after having tried it, now we trust it less as a community of developers. Not, not, we don't, that number didn't go down a whole lot. It went down by like, I'm going to say five to ten percent. I can't remember the exact figures. But yeah, like many people who work in any kind of corporate enterprise, there's been a lot of fuss over AI, right? And every time I have, I'm going to say, I'm going to say,
我想其中一个观点是，你知道，在尝试过之后，我们作为一个开发者社区现在对它的信任度降低了。不是说，我们不是，那个数字并没有下降太多。大概下降了百分之五到百分之十。我不记得确切的数字了。但是，是的，就像许多在任何类型的企业中工作的人一样，关于 AI 的炒作非常多，对吧？每次我，我得说，我得说，
say tried using AI, been subjected to using AI as maybe another term I could use, it hasn't really gone well. You know, I've had AI do code reviews on my code. It turned out to be very good at making work for people and saving no time at all. In fact, the opposite. I've seen AI leave so many comments on pull requests that I basically couldn't load the pull request in the browser anymore. That pull request had to die because it could not be reviewed because the AI had left so many comments, it had basically killed the experience. It just wouldn't load. Is this on GitHub? GetLab? Yeah, on GitHub. Wow. I've seen AI leave a dozen comments on one of my pull requests. And here's the thing. The suggestions always sound good on the surface. But when you
说尝试使用 AI，或者说被迫使用 AI，这可能是另一个词，结果并不怎么好。你知道，我让 AI 对我的代码进行过代码审查。结果它非常擅长给人们制造额外的工作，却一点时间也没节省。事实上，恰恰相反。我见过 AI 在合并请求（pull request）上留下了太多的评论，以至于我基本上无法在浏览器中加载那个合并请求了。那个合并请求不得不作废，因为它无法被审查，因为 AI 留下的评论太多，基本上毁了整个体验。它就是加载不出来。这是在 GitHub 上吗？GitLab？是的，在 GitHub 上。哇。我见过 AI 在我的一个合并请求上留下了十几条评论。问题就在这里。这些建议表面上听起来都不错。但当你
dig into them and it takes you a half an hour to go through each one and think, okay, you know, and it suggests writing this test or writing that test or doing this or doing that. And in one particular case, in this case, I'm thinking about all of them turned out to be wrong. It was zero for 12 on its suggestions. But it took, it took 45 minutes to figure that out, right? as a human, right? It took, it was, it's like dealing with, I've heard it described as being, it's like dealing with a brand new developer who you have to train, except they never learn. Right. Right. You always have to tell them what to do. They never learn. And, you know, I don't really have time for that. I have a lot of time for teaching people who will learn,
深入研究它们时，你需要花半个小时去逐一思考，好吧，你知道，它建议写这个测试或那个测试，或者做这个或那个。在其中一个特定的案例中，我想到的所有建议最终都是错的。它的建议是 12 投 0 中。但作为一个人类，弄清楚这一点花了 45 分钟，对吧？这就像处理，我听过有人这样描述，就像处理一个你需要培训的新手开发者，只不过他们永远学不会。对吧。对吧。你总是得告诉他们该做什么。他们永远学不会。而且，你知道，我真的没时间做那个。我有大把时间去教那些会学习的人，
but not for teaching AIs who won't. Are you, I'm not sure if you're allowed to say what, because I know it sounds like you're using like GitHub, agent or CodeRabbit or one of those tools? I don't actually know. Okay. There are internal tools that we use. We do use GitHub. I mean, we use GitHub as for our regular development.
但没时间教那些不会学习的 AI。我不确定你是否能说出，因为听起来你用的是 GitHub Copilot、CodeRabbit 或类似的工具？我其实不知道。好吧。我们使用一些内部工具。我们确实使用 GitHub。我的意思是，我们使用 GitHub 进行日常开发。
But as far as the AI specifics go, I can tell you, because I actually don't know. Okay. But anyways, it was some kind of code review tool that was leaving automated. This particular one, yeah. Yeah. And have, is that the main experience? And maybe, and, well, you know, I have colleagues who use AI and who find it useful. You know, it's horses for courses.
但就 AI 的具体细节而言，我无法告诉你，因为我确实不知道。好吧。但无论如何，那是一种会留下自动评论的代码审查工具。就是这一款，是的。是的。这是你的主要体验吗？也许，嗯，你知道，我有同事使用 AI 并觉得它很有用。你知道，萝卜青菜，各有所爱。
The kind of work I do. Horses for courses. What does that mean? It means different things are suited to different jobs. Okay, okay. I guess. Sorry, it's a Britishism. You know, for some kinds of work, like, like, if you do work that's like summarizing documents or, you know,
我做的那种工作。萝卜青菜，各有所爱。那是什么意思？意思是不同的事物适合不同的工作。好吧，好吧。我猜。抱歉，这是个英国俚语。你知道，对于某些类型的工作，比如，如果你做的工作是总结文档，或者，你知道，
I don't know because I don't do that kind of work, but I'm sure there are many areas where AI can be useful to pull things out. But if you're doing work programming, in particular, if you're programming and your aim is to provide lasting value in the code base, then I don't think AI currently helps you.
我不知道，因为我不做那种工作，但我相信有很多领域 AI 可以用来提取信息。但如果你是在做编程工作，特别是如果你编程的目标是在代码库中提供持久的价值，那么我不认为 AI 目前能帮到你。
And bonus, it's environmentally extremely unfriendly as well. So not only does it not help, it's very bad to the moment. I mean, we can definitely agree that it's bad for the environment. I mean, most of the AI people that are pro-AI, I should say, they say that, you know, oh, we get to a certain point and then we can fix all our problems with AI that is predicated on getting to that point. Well, yeah, it's predicated and getting at that point.
而且额外的一点是，它在环境方面也极其不友好。所以它不仅没有帮助，而且目前来看非常糟糕。我的意思是，我们绝对可以同意它对环境有害。我的意思是，大多数支持 AI 的人，我应该说，他们会说，你知道，哦，我们达到某个点之后，就可以用 AI 解决我们所有的问题，但这前提是能达到那个点。嗯，是的，前提是达到那个点。
In the meantime, you know, data centers are projected to be the energy cost of the fifth largest country in the world. And, you know, according to many reports, the cost of a simple web search has gone up by 5x in terms of the environmental cost. Oh, right, because, yeah, Google is prefixing all your questions with a little AI summary answer. So, you know, maybe I'm old and commodgingly. Maybe I'm old and wise. You can decide. But, you know, I don't think, I don't want to, I don't want to do that. Also, to my previous point, if our job as developers is to add lasting value, right? I have not yet seen a case where AI really helps with that.
与此同时，你知道，数据中心的能源成本预计将达到世界第五大国家的水平。而且，根据许多报告，一次简单的网络搜索在环境成本方面增加了 5 倍。哦，对，因为，是的，谷歌在你的所有问题前都加上了一个简短的 AI 总结答案。所以，你知道，也许我老了，是个老顽固。也许我老而睿智。你可以自己决定。但是，你知道，我不认为，我不想，我不想那样做。另外，回到我之前的观点，如果我们的工作作为开发者是增加持久的价值，对吧？我还没有看到 AI 在这方面真正有帮助的案例。
I'm sure AI is great at producing code, right? It's great at solving problems if you want to throw away the solution. But I don't think it's very great at solving problems over time, solving software engineering problems. So let me ask you your experience there. I mean, I think you might be right in the moment, but I'm also not sure. I definitely can say anecdotally for myself, I find these tools like crazy force multipliers, even for like non-coding tasks now. Like there's so many times now I reach for these tools when I just need to solve some problem
我相信 AI 在生成代码方面很棒，对吧？如果你想扔掉解决方案，它在解决问题方面很棒。但我不认为它在长期解决问题、解决软件工程问题方面很擅长。所以让我问问你的经验。我的意思是，我觉得你当下的看法可能是对的，但我也不确定。我绝对可以从个人经历中说，我发现这些工具即使在非编码任务中也是疯狂的倍增器。现在有很多时候，当我需要解决某个问题时，我都会去使用这些工具，
that is sometimes just in the real world. like for instance over the weekend we were at a shima and i were at a different place not our own and we were trying to watch and or season two fantastic show if you haven't seen it and season one and uh we had it i had it on my laptop and we were trying to um with an hdmi cable displayed on the tv that was in this place we were staying at and it was 4k so like the rates were super choppy and i don't know how to fix that so i went and asked it and actually i went in just got cursor, because now, like, I'm on my laptop, and I just say, hey, I don't actually need you to write any code for me. I just need help. This 4K TV is choppy. Can you fix it?
有时只是现实生活中的问题。例如，周末我和 Shima 在一个不是我们自己的地方，我们想看《熊家餐馆》（The Bear）第二季，如果你没看过的话，这是一部很棒的剧，还有第一季。我把它放在我的笔记本电脑上，我们试图用 HDMI 线把它投到我们住的地方的电视上，那是 4K 的，所以帧率超级卡顿，我不知道怎么解决。所以我去问了它，实际上我直接用了 Cursor，因为现在，我在笔记本电脑上，我只是说，嘿，我其实不需要你为我写任何代码。我只需要帮助。这台 4K 电视很卡。你能修好它吗？
And a minute later, it basically has run a couple commands using this tool called XRand, which I've never heard of before. And it basically, it did some XRand list where it found the sources, it found the 4K TV, and it said, okay, let's just switch this to, I think it was 60 frames per second instead of 120 or something completely solved the issue. I didn't even know this tool existed. I'm sure I could have using Google searches, like gotten to the solution eventually, but it definitely would have taken way longer than 60 seconds. And that is like a concrete thing where, you know, it is actually solved a real-life problem
一分钟后，它基本上使用了一个叫 XRand 的工具运行了几个命令，我以前从没听说过这个工具。它基本上做了一些 XRand 列表，找到了源，找到了 4K 电视，然后说，好吧，让我们把它切换到，我想是每秒 60 帧，而不是 120 帧或者其他什么，问题完全解决了。我甚至不知道这个工具存在。我相信如果我用谷歌搜索，最终也能找到解决方案，但肯定会比 60 秒花的时间长得多。这是一个具体的例子，你知道，它确实解决了一个现实生活中的问题，
for me, like over the weekend. Right. So I definitely think that these tools can be useful. Are they creating lasting value? I guess that's TBD. I mean, I know a lot of these companies that are writing these tools are kind of like dog fooding, and there are, I don't know what the numbers are of the number of developers that are using these tools, but to a certain extent a lot of folks seem to be getting value out of this stuff.
对我来说，就像周末那样。对。所以我绝对认为这些工具是有用的。它们在创造持久的价值吗？我想这还有待观察。我的意思是，我知道很多编写这些工具的公司都在进行“狗粮自食”（dogfooding），我不知道有多少开发者在使用这些工具，但在某种程度上，很多人似乎确实从中获得了价值。
I will say that I have a developing view that there are certain types of work, potentially all the code that you're writing, you know, template, metaprogramming, variatic, C++, you know, on embedded software that it's terrible for. And you can throw, you know, writing kuda kernels in that category of stuff that it's just, it's not going to help you when the, for a certain set,
我得说，我有一个正在形成的观点，即某些类型的工作，可能你写的所有代码，你知道，模板、元编程、变参 C++，你知道，在嵌入式软件上，它表现得很糟糕。你可以把编写 CUDA 内核归入那一类，它在某些情况下根本帮不上忙，
like define some parameters on, you know, very complicated code. It's not good at doing that. But if you need help spinning up some kind of like single page application that, you know, is just statically serving you some information, like Shima now is using these tools to like, build like
比如在非常复杂的代码上定义一些参数。它不擅长做那个。但如果你需要帮助搭建某种单页应用程序，你知道，只是静态地为你提供一些信息，比如 Shima 现在正在使用这些工具来构建，比如
like basically personal websites that are helping her with her job in terms of I mean Bryce and I talked about the the Ohip codes but she started building another one for basically medical prescription translations if you want to get
基本上是个人网站，在她的工作中帮助她，我的意思是，我和 Bryce 谈过 OHIP 代码，但她开始构建另一个，基本上是用于医疗处方翻译，如果你想让
you know someone with you know certain medical thing on there on one drug but you want to taper them off onto some other drug there's like some complicated like math that goes into doing that and right now when you're an addiction doctor you basically just do that personally like by hand and it's but it's very like you're doing the same thing every single time but there's like a huge matrix of like are they taking pills is it ivy i don't know all the details right but it's like a very complex matrix of stuff
你知道，某人正在服用某种药物，但你想让他们逐渐减量换成另一种药物，这中间有一些复杂的数学计算。目前，当你是一名成瘾科医生时，你基本上是亲自手动完成的。但它非常，你每次都在做同样的事情，但有一个巨大的矩阵，比如他们是在吃药还是静脉注射，我不知道所有细节，但它就像一个非常复杂的矩阵，
and she said it would be amazing and there are actually websites that she's she mentioned md calc which is this kind of website that doctors do utilize but it's only for a certain set of these calculations um and she said like if i could have one specifically for my thing this would save me like over my career, potentially like weeks and weeks of work, because it's just, it's stuff that you could do with some kind of medical calculator. It just doesn't exist, right? Someone's not going to go and build a one-off thing for that bespoke thing. I would love to, I would love to hear Shima's opinions. And I think you and she should, if she's willing, you should record with her. Because, you know, other way, this podcast is in the genre of two guys talking. And
她说如果能有一个专门针对我的事情的工具会很棒，实际上她提到的 MD Calc 这种网站，医生确实会使用，但它只针对其中一部分计算。她说，如果我能有一个专门针对我的事情的工具，这在我的职业生涯中可能会节省数周的工作量，因为它只是那种你可以用某种医疗计算器完成的事情。它只是不存在，对吧？别人不会去为那种定制的事情专门构建一个一次性的东西。我很想听听 Shima 的意见。我觉得如果她愿意，你应该和她一起录制。因为，你知道，无论如何，这个播客属于两个男人谈话的类型，而
Sometimes it's you and Bryce, and sometimes it's you and me. But either way, the genre of two guys talking is not what the world needs, I think, sometimes. So I'd love to hear Seema's opinion, you know, as medical professional, as a woman, as someone who's not in the same demographic. Yeah, I mean, we, well, if you want to be on, she'd be happy to come on. In fact, we were talking about it back in June, and we were going to record. But then I said, oh, really, we should, we should try and get Ben, because, I live a little bit more in her world, so probably I'm not the best person to ask, like, questions.
有时是你和 Bryce，有时是你和我。但无论如何，两个男人谈话的类型，我认为有时并不是世界所需要的。所以我很想听听 Seema 的意见，你知道，作为一名医疗专业人士，作为一名女性，作为一名不在同一人口统计学群体中的人。是的，我的意思是，我们，嗯，如果你想让她上节目，她会很乐意来的。事实上，我们早在六月份就谈过这件事，我们本来打算录制的。但我当时说，哦，真的，我们应该，我们应该试着找 Ben，因为，我生活在她的世界里多一点，所以我可能不是问问题的最佳人选。
Better to be, have some third party, aka you. Sure. I'd be happy to do that. Because the interesting overlap here is that, you know, the other big problem with AI is, for me, is AI cannot take accountability for code, right? There's a legal problem, right? If I'm an engineer writing some code,
最好是有第三方，也就是你。当然。我很乐意这样做。因为这里有趣的重叠点是，你知道，AI 的另一个大问题，对我来说，是 AI 无法为代码承担责任，对吧？这是一个法律问题，对吧？如果我是一名编写代码的工程师，
I need to be able to take accountability for that. If I'm using AI, LLMs to write it, where's the accountability? Like, this is why I say, it might be okay for like throwaway things, right? But I am not going to have an LLM write my code, and then I have to stand behind that code. Right. And so if an LLM writes it, I still have to write it, right? I still have to read every part of it. I still have to understand every part of it.
我需要能够为代码承担责任。如果我使用 AI、大语言模型（LLM）来编写它，责任在哪里？这就是为什么我说，它可能适合一些一次性的东西，对吧？但我不会让大语言模型写我的代码，然后我还要为那段代码背书。对吧。所以如果大语言模型写了它，我仍然必须写它，对吧？我仍然必须阅读它的每一部分。我仍然必须理解它的每一部分。
Like the typing of the code is not the slow part there. In fact, the more code produced, the less I'm likely to understand it. Right. There is definitely a dichotomy between the vibe coding stuff that's like a personal thing versus stuff that you're shipping to production.
就像代码的输入并不是慢的部分。事实上，生成的代码越多，我理解它的可能性就越小。对吧。在那种“氛围编码”（vibe coding）的个人事务与你发布到生产环境的代码之间，绝对存在一种二分法。
And I will say, like, I have used the code-assisted tools to help with writing libraries, but that is much different because I'm actually reviewing all the code that's being written there. It's still, of course, multiplier, but it's not the same as,
我得说，我确实使用过代码辅助工具来帮助编写库，但这非常不同，因为我实际上在审查所有正在编写的代码。它仍然是倍增器，但它与
oh, I have this dashboard that I want to build. and I can just spin it up. And I really don't care of the JavaScript that it generates. I just know what I want it to look like, and I can verify what it looks like at the end of the day to know that it's correct, you know. And in the case where you have to verify everything,
哦，我有一个想要构建的仪表板，我可以随手搭建起来，这完全不同。我真的不在乎它生成的 JavaScript。我只知道我想要它看起来是什么样，并且我可以在一天结束时验证它看起来是否正确，你知道。而在你需要验证一切的情况下，
you know, there is one data point, one study that's been done that I'm aware of, which I think someone mentioned on the GitHub for one of the last episodes. There is one study so far, and it showed that developers think they are 2020, 25% faster. The data shows they are 20 to 25% slower. But even when confronted with the data, of course, the classic thing is they still believe they're 20 to 25% faster. I have to say,
你知道，有一个数据点，一项已经完成的研究，我所知道的，我想有人在 GitHub 上为最后几期节目中的一期提到过。目前只有一项研究，它显示开发者认为他们快了 20% 到 25%。数据表明他们慢了 20% 到 25%。但即使面对数据，当然，经典的情况是他们仍然认为自己快了 20% 到 25%。我不得不说，
Connor, your response to that was perfect. You just said, well, I flat out don't believe the study. I'm going to call you out on that. You know, so I think there is this, maybe it does reflect this dichotomy of like vibe coding. You can produce a lot of code. But coding when it matters, which frankly is the code that I want to do professionally, right? I don't. want to be vibe coding on stuff that doesn't matter. When it matters, it's not speeding us up. I mean, that's where I, I mean, like I said, I do think that my developing view is that there are types of coding that it helps you for and other types that it is much less helpful for. That, I mean, that being said, I'll read because Ben is not mistaken. He did, he did read my
Connor，你对此的回应非常完美。你只是说，嗯，我完全不相信这项研究。我要质疑你。你知道，所以我认为这可能确实反映了这种“氛围编码”的二分法。你可以产生很多代码。但在重要的时候进行编码，坦率地说，那是我想要专业地去做的代码，对吧？我不想在无关紧要的事情上进行“氛围编码”。当它重要时，它并没有加快我们的速度。我的意思是，这就是我，我的意思是，就像我说的，我确实认为我正在形成的观点是，有些类型的编码它能帮到你，而其他类型它就没那么有用了。也就是说，我会读一下，因为 Ben 没有弄错。他确实读了我的
reply in the first sentence is anything. And so the, this is, well, let's see if we can get their name. Their handle is M. Heyman, which is for Michael Heyman. So this was on episode 244. They posted, so there's this measuring the impact of early 2025 AI on experienced open source developer productivity that just came out saying what Ben just mentioned. And we'll skip over the rest of their post. I replied saying anything that says Gen AI tools are slowing people down, I just don't believe. And then I'll skip the next thing I said. But I pulled out two things. I didn't read the study in full, to be fair, but they were using Cloud 3.5 and 3 points on it.
回复的第一句话是什么。所以，这个，嗯，让我们看看能不能找到他们的名字。他们的账号是 M. Heyman，代表 Michael Heyman。所以这是在第 244 期。他们发布了，所以有一篇《衡量 2025 年初 AI 对经验丰富的开源开发者生产力的影响》的研究刚刚发布，说的就是 Ben 刚才提到的内容。我们跳过他们帖子的其余部分。我回复说，任何说生成式 AI 工具正在拖慢人们速度的说法，我都不相信。然后我跳过了我说的下一件事。但我提取了两点。公平地说，我没有完整阅读这项研究，但他们使用的是 Claude 3.5 和 3 点。
So I understand that when you do a study, you're doing the latest and greatest, and probably that was the latest and greatest at the time. But my first remark is, do this study again with Cloud 4 and see what they say. And the other thing is, I wanted to see, like, who are these folks? Like, what is experienced? Because it's kind of like, the analogy I had in my head is if, like, if you're going to go to some race car track or some F1 circuit, and then you get some, like, moderately experienced, which is what they say in the paper.
所以我明白，当你做一项研究时，你使用的是最新最好的，而且那可能在当时是最新最好的。但我的第一个评论是，用 Claude 4 再做一次这项研究，看看他们怎么说。另一件事是，我想看看，这些人是谁？“经验丰富”是什么意思？因为这有点像，我脑子里的类比是，如果，如果你要去某个赛车场或 F1 赛道，然后你找了一些，比如，中等经验的，这就是他们在论文中所说的。
They say it's 16 developers with moderate AI experience and you put them in some car that doesn't really show like what you can do with the car. But if you get, you know, the best drivers in the world or whatever, the people that are the power users of these tools and see what they can do, that's actually measuring like what the car can do. So it might not be a perfect analogy,
他们说这是 16 名具有中等 AI 经验的开发者，你把他们放在某种车里，这并不能真正展示你能用这辆车做什么。但如果你找来，你知道，世界上最好的车手，或者其他什么人，那些这些工具的超级用户，看看他们能做什么，那才是真正衡量这辆车能做什么。所以这可能不是一个完美的类比，
but I kind of thought, you know, the lack of detail on how much experience do these folks like have with the AI tools, it doesn't it's not a super fair to say that like oh these people and if your point is like well what if we just unleash these tools on the world like what impact is it going to have okay maybe that's fair yeah i mean i i i don't think you can dismiss that point because they're not power users if they're representative of your your regular working programmer then it's not just you know what's the cost of unleashing these tools on the world the question is like
但我有点认为，你知道，缺乏关于这些人对 AI 工具到底有多少经验的细节，说“哦，这些人”并不是很公平。如果你的观点是“好吧，如果我们只是把这些工具释放到世界上会怎样？它会产生什么影响？”好吧，也许这很公平。是的，我的意思是，我不认为你可以忽视这一点，因为他们不是超级用户。如果他们代表了你的普通在职程序员，那么这不仅仅是“释放这些工具到世界上的成本是多少”，问题在于
are the economics even there, right, regardless of the other externalities? Economics meaning... Like, is it worth it for companies to adopt these things, which they are trying to do in droves? Right, I see. You're saying that companies don't employ just the power users of whatever tools they're using. There's a distribution of folks. Right, and everything's on the power curve. So your power users are like 2, 3% of your users, right? Maybe. I'm all parking.
经济效益是否存在，对吧，不管其他外部因素如何？经济效益是指……就像，公司采用这些东西是否值得，而他们正成群结队地试图这样做？对，我明白了。你是说公司雇佣的不仅仅是他们所用工具的超级用户。人群中存在分布。对，一切都在能力曲线上。所以你的超级用户大概占你用户的 2%、3%，对吧？也许。我只是随便说说。
Right, right. But like, yeah, I guess that's fair. I mean, I'm just saying, like, it's fair to say, like, this is not my personal experience. But I don't think we get to reject the finding. Yeah, maybe that's true. I mean, I still, in my heart of hearts, find it hard to believe. I mean, Richard Feldman, who has his own podcast, Software Unscripted, he just had Chris Latimer on for the second time talking.
对，对。但就像，是的，我想这很公平。我的意思是，我只是说，公平地说，这不是我的个人经历。但我不认为我们可以拒绝这个发现。是的，也许那是真的。我的意思是，我内心深处仍然觉得很难相信。我的意思是，Richard Feldman，他有自己的播客《Software Unscripted》，他刚刚第二次请 Chris Latimer 来谈论
about Mojo primarily. But obviously, they're talking about AI as well. And at one point, Richard said that he just didn't believe, like, when people are throwing out, like, 10x and 100x productivity gains, he had some quote where it was like, you know, you can see 100x from space. Like, there's no way anyone's having that kind of, like, productivity gain. Well, I think that my biggest pet peeve with the hype is when people start throwing around numbers like 10x, 100x.
Mojo。但显然，他们也在谈论 AI。在某个时刻，Richard 说他就是不相信，当人们抛出 10 倍和 100 倍的生产力提升时，他有一句名言，大意是，你知道，你可以从太空中看到 100 倍。没有人能有那种生产力提升。嗯，我认为我对这种炒作最大的不满是当人们开始抛出 10 倍、100 倍这样的数字时。
Like, you know, I appreciate that at the beginning of the conversation, you were very quick to be like, hey, we're not saying we're 10x faster than Rust, right? But like with AI hype, it's like the opposite. Someone's like, we're 100 X is productive. And I'm just like, wait a minute, wait a minute. Like, you can see the outputs of 100x productivity from space. Like, if you're actually 100x productive, you don't need to tell anyone about that. You just have people walking by with their jaws open at like what you're producing.
就像，你知道，我很欣赏在对话开始时，你很快就说，嘿，我们不是说我们比 Rust 快 10 倍，对吧？但对于 AI 炒作，情况恰恰相反。有人说，我们生产力提高了 100 倍。我只是觉得，等一下，等一下。就像，你可以从太空中看到 100 倍生产力的产出。如果你真的提高了 100 倍的生产力，你不需要告诉任何人。你只需要让人们走过时下巴掉下来，看着你正在生产的东西。
And they're like, how are you possibly outputting this much, which of course is not happening. Correct. 100%. Yeah. Yeah. And in my head, in my head I was screaming like, well, it's, I think it's like for certain people like Shima, who admittedly, she actually at a internship or at some point in her life was actually, did do a little bit of MATLAB in some research position back when she was, I think, in her undergrad, so many years ago. So it's not like she has zero programming experience, but she definitely would not call herself a programmer. But the kind of apps that...
他们会说，你怎么可能产出这么多，当然这并没有发生。正确。100%。是的。是的。在我脑子里，我一直在尖叫，好吧，它是，我认为这就像对于像 Shima 这样的人，她确实，在实习期间或她生命中的某个时刻，确实在本科时做过一点 MATLAB 研究，那是很多年前的事了。所以她并不是完全没有编程经验，但她绝对不会称自己为程序员。但她能构建的那种应用程序……
But she's, you know, she's a doctor. she is well qualified in a technical field right I'm sure she's done plenty of math in her yes yes yeah at one point yeah she considered pursuing a career in mathematics um but the point being is the apps that she is able to build with these tools is something that's like without going and you know developing a whole different vertical skill set she is incapable of doing so that's like it's zero to like impossible to possible so like if you we're measuring, like, productivity improvements, it's like, well, that's something that she would have to go spend days, weeks, like, however long getting up to speed where she could build
但她，你知道，她是一名医生。她在技术领域很有资格，对吧？我相信她在数学方面做过很多，是的，是的，是的，在某个时刻，是的，她考虑过从事数学职业，嗯，但重点是，她能够用这些工具构建的应用程序，是那种如果不去，你知道，开发一套完全不同的垂直技能集，她是无法做到的。所以这就像是从零到不可能变为可能。所以，如果我们正在衡量，比如，生产力提升，这就像，嗯，那是她必须花几天、几周，无论多久才能达到能构建那种东西的水平。所以，从这个意义上说，难道不是超过 100 倍吗？就像，而且我觉得人们，在这项研究中也是，他们主要衡量的是 GitHub 仓库上的开源问题。是的。嗯，他们试图衡量，比如，一份正常的工作，对吧？我想他们试图找一些普通程序员做他们日常工作中会做的代表性事情，对吧？这和 Shima 不同，对吧？
that. So, like, in that sense, like, isn't it greater than 100x? Like, it's, and I feel like people, like, in this study, too, the, the thing that they're primarily measuring is open issues on open source, like GitHub repositories. Yeah. Well, they tried to measure, like, a regular day job, right? I think they tried to take Hira regular programmers doing a representative thing they would do during their day, right? And that's different from Shima, right?
Shima 的主要工作不是写代码。这是她工作中非常、非常小的一部分。现在，如果她能放大这一点，那很好。但最终，这占了多少？她工作的 2%、5%？我不知道。但它不是，你知道，它不是她工作的重点。是的，我想那是真的。
Shima's main job is not writing code. It's a very, very small part of her job. Now, if she can amplify that, then it's great. But in the end, what does that account for? 2%, 5% of her job? I don't know. But it's not, you know, it's not the focus of her job. Yeah, I guess that's true.
我猜。我应该说我在猜。嗯，她构建的工具只是为了帮助她自己。它不是，是的，也许不能代表大多数。我想这是一个问题，世界上发生的软件开发、软件工程和代码编写的饼图是什么样的？因为这会影响，我猜，人们的生产力将如何被放大。我认为它最好的情况是，你从零到 100 构建你想要的某个工具或某个网站，它会完成所有的脚手架，
I'm guessing. I should say I'm guessing. Well, the tools that she's building are just to help her. It's not, it's, yeah, maybe not indicative of the majority. I guess that's a question is, what is the pie chart of software development and software engineering and code writing that happens in the world? Because that affects, I guess, how people are going to have their productivity amplified. The cases where I think it's like the best is where you're going from zero to 100 of some tool that you want or some website that you want, and it's going to do all the scaffolding,
所有的设置。就像今天早上，我写了一个我称之为 STT 的工具，即语音转文字，因为我像，我花太多时间向这些模型口述，或者说，我应该说，打字，目前是这样。我基本上只想对它说话。我在 Linux 上看了一下。有几个不同的选项，但 Speech Note，排名第一的推荐选项，因为某种原因无法工作，然后第二个选项就是使用 OpenAI 的 Whisper。
all the setup. Like just this morning, I wrote a tool that I called STT, which is speech to text, because I'm like, I'm spending so much time dictating to these models that like, or typing, I should say, at the moment. I just basically want to speak to it. And I looked on Linux. There was a couple different options, but speech note, the number one recommended one, didn't work for some reason, and then the second option was just to use opening eyes whisper.
有趣。无论如何，所以我只是构建，我只是问它，嘿，你为我写了这个脚本来运行这个工具，把它扔进一个小 GUI 里。但我主要想要的就是回车录音，回车停止，然后转录完成后，把它复制到剪贴板，这样我就可以立即 Ctrl+V 到代理窗口中。在 10 分钟内，我就完成了。我的意思是，它确实需要弄清楚一些 TK，Enter，Tickle TK，那里有
Interesting. Anyway, so I just built, I just asked it, like, hey, you wrote me this script to run this tool, throw it in a little gooey. But the main thing I want is just like enter to record, enter to stop, and then when it's done transcribing, copy it to the clipboard so that I can just immediately control V it into the agent window. And within like 10 minutes, I was done. I mean, it did have to figure out some TK, enter, Tickle TK, there was
一些问题，但那只是在我的桌面上，它修复了它，但就像，我不知道，350 行 Python 代码，我不知道那会花我多长时间，但我保证我至少节省了 10 倍的时间，就像，我不可能去写一个 350 行的 Python 脚本，利用 Tkinter 和 Whisper 以及一堆我从未摆弄过的东西，就像，那至少要花我一天时间，对吧？而且这也基于一个想法，即如果你进行语音转文字，你可以比打字更舒服地说话，而且对于长时间的文本，我认为对某些人来说这是真的，也许对大多数人来说这是一个巨大的无障碍提升。我会说，我认为对某些人来说，这个命题是一个
some issue but that was just like on my desktop and it fixed it but like it's like i don't know 350 lines of python code i don't know how long that would have taken me but i guarantee you i saved at least like 10x uh like there's no way i'm going to write a 350 line python script that's making use of tk inter and whisper and a bunch of stuff that like sure i've never messed around with like it's going to take me at least a date right like and that's it's also predicated on the idea that you can speak comfortably faster than you can type comfortably for extended if you're doing text to speech and I think for some folks that's true maybe for most folks it's a great accessibility gain I would say I think for some folks that that proposition is a
充其量是边际收益，你知道，有些人打字比说话快得多。我，你知道，我有一个朋友使用速记键盘。哦，是的，你，我们曾经聊过这个，对吧，对吧，对吧。所以这是一种正在消亡的艺术，但它通过，你知道，小众互联网，正在某种程度上回归。所以如果，你知道，如果你是一名经验丰富的速记员，你可以每分钟打 250 个字，你可以整天打字而不会患上 RSI（重复性劳损），对吧？对。但那又是一个小众的东西。我认为对大多数人来说，确实，语音转文字是一种生产力提升，
marginal marginal win at best you know some folks can type a lot faster than they can speak I you know I have a friend who uses a stenography keyboard oh yeah you yeah we chatted about this once yeah yeah yeah so it's a dying art but it's sort of coming back through you know the niche the niche internet um so it's a thing if you know and if you're an experienced stenographer you can type at 250 words a minute and you can type all day long with with no rSI right right so but that again is a niche thing i think for most people it's true text to speech is a productivity gain
也是一种无障碍提升，我们这么说吧。这也意味着，我只在 Shima 不在的时候使用它，因为如果我一直自言自语，我可能会把她逼疯。是的，有一些
an accessibility gain let's say as well it also means like I only use it when when she was not around because I'd probably drive her nuts just talking to myself Yeah there are some
是的，完全正确。而且你知道，我们会在某个时候搬家，然后我有我自己的房间，然后好吧，我可以关上门，我就不会惹恼她，希望她会
Yeah exactly And you know We move at some point Then I have my own room Then okay I could close the door And I won't irritate her And hopefully she'll be
在无论我们身处何地的另一个角落。但所有这些都是说，就像，这是一个工具的例子，它绝对，就像，总共花了我 10 或 15 分钟，我不知道它是否是一天，我不知道它是否是半周，但就像，生产力，我制作那个工具的能力至少快了 10 倍。这就是那种，就像我说的，我从零到 100。如果你正在处理一个现有的非常老的遗留代码库，或者甚至不是遗留代码库，也许它是去年构建的，但你知道，它是数万甚至数十万，天哪，数百万行代码，而你正在处理
At a different Different corner of whatever the place we're at But this all to be said Is that like This is an example Of a tool that like definitely like it took me like grand total like 10 or 15 minutes and I don't know if it's a day I don't know if it's half a week but like the product like my ability to make that tool is like at least 10x faster this is the type of thing where like I said I'm going from zero to 100 if you're working on an existing very like old legacy or not even legacy code base maybe it was built in the last year but you know it's tens of thousands if not hundreds of thousands heaven forbid millions of lines of code and you're working on you
你只是一堆未解决的问题，潜在的生产力提升，你会达到的。就像如果所有的，你知道，就像我知道你的工作流程，你已经设置好了所有的花哨功能。你有你的测试框架
you just have a bunch of open issues, potentially the productivity you're going to gain, you're going to get there. Like if all the, you know, like I know your workflow, you have all the bells and whistles already set up. You've got your testing frameworks
和你的 clang-tidy 和格式化工具。是的。如果所有这些东西都已经完成了，而你唯一需要帮助的就是基本上解决这些未解决的问题，无论它们是简单的还是棘手的，你可能，呃，
and your clang tides and formats. Yeah. And if all that stuff is already done, and the only thing you need help with is basically solving these open issues, whether they're simple or gnarly, you're probably, uh,
它们是什么，你的里程可能会有所不同（mileage may vary）。就像，你从这些工具中获得的里程，绝对远低于从零到 100 的用例。嗯，让我们面对现实吧，这些 AI 工具在搭建样板代码方面很棒，比如启动一个新项目。
what are they, your mileage may vary. Like the, the mileage that you're going to get out of these tools is, is, definitely way less than the zero to 100 use case. Well, and let's face it, these AI tools are great at spinning up boilerplate, like spinning up a new project.
但让我们在这里明确一点，我们需要它们来做这件事其实挺可悲的。就像启动一个新项目，即使在 C++ 中，即使有依赖项，也应该是，我可以在几分钟内完成。我不需要使用工具，对吧？如果你有特定的工作流程，如果你像我为我的专业环境那样设置好了东西，
But let's actually be clear here, it's pretty sad that we need them to do that. Like spinning up a new project, even in C++, even with dependencies, ought to be, I can do it in a couple of minutes. I don't need to use a tool, right? and if you have a certain workflow and if you have things set up like I do for my professional environment
它已经是那样了。是的，我的意思是，我 100% 同意，当我和 Bryce 聊天时，我发表过评论，我说也许是因为 C++ 体验的痛苦，我
it is that way already Yeah I mean I made that is a 100% agree and I made a comment when I was chatting with Bryce that I said maybe it was because of the painfulness of the C++ experience that I
喜欢这些工具，而且有很多人对它并不感到兴奋。我提到了 Rust 和 Ruby，因为那些是，我随口想到的，我知道的两个语言，它们真的，真的试图确保那些语言的工具和生态系统体验非常好。所以，如果你在 Rust 中，当你所要做的只是 rustup，你知道，我不，你记不住那些命令是什么，但它基本上只是几个
I like these tools and there's a ton of people that are not thrilled with it and I mentioned Rust and Ruby because those are you know, off the top of my head, two languages that I know that really, really are tried to make sure that the tooling and the ecosystem experience of those languages is really good. So potentially if you're in Rust, when all you have to do is rust up, you know, I don't and you can't remember what the Canaan's are, but it's just basically a couple to
安装最新的 Rust，然后 cargo init，我想，去，它们甚至初始化，你就像，Hello World。然后你就开始比赛了。而且你内置了单元测试，基本上就像语言和文档。所有这些东西。所以，如果你是一名 Rust 开发者，你从这些模型中获得的价值可能比你在 C++ 这种有更多工具和生态系统问题的语言中要少得多。别误会我，C++ 在过去十年中取得了巨大的进步。
install the latest Rust and then cargo and knit, I think, to, and they even initialize, you're like, Hello World. And then you're off to the races. And you've got unit tests built in to basically like the language and document. all that stuff. So potentially the value that you get from, you know, these models if you're a Rust developer is a lot less than if you're in a language like C++ or that has a lot more tooling in ecosystem, ecosystem problems. And don't get me wrong, C++ has made massive improvements over the last decade.
但我认为还有很长的路要走。嗯，而且不仅仅是语言细节。这就是我戴上我那顶非常老的老顽固帽子的地方。而且，你知道，提到那些使用命令行的人，使用 Emacs 的人，使用 VIM 的人。通常，你会发现，作为一个整体，在这些人中，他们在做事情上要高效得多，你知道，嗯，我说在命令行上做事情。显然，那是一个同义反复。但他们在使用工具方面比，你知道，那些没学过这些、习惯使用更多 GUI 导向工具的人更高效。
But there's still a long way to go, I think. Well, and it's not just language specifics either. This is where I get to put on my really old commmergent. hat. And, you know, bring up people who use command line, people who use Emacs, people who use VIM. Generally, you find, as a whole, among those kind of folks, they are much more efficient at doing things on the, you know, well, I say doing things on the command line. Obviously, that's a tautology. But they're more efficient at using the tools than, you know, folks who haven't learned that and are used to using the more GUI-oriented tools.
甚至，你知道，即使是像 VS Code 这样的现代编辑器，它们也有很多花哨的功能。它们确实有很多东西在里面。但它们没有那种在 VIM 和 Emacs 等环境中持续了 40 年的对编辑的专注，对吧？对。而且，你知道，我知道我听起来像什么，我知道我听起来像什么。我的意思是，人们总是说，学习你的工具，它将为你服务一生，对吧？是的，是的。
And even, you know, even modern editors like VS code, they have a lot of bells and whistles. They do have a lot of things in there. But they don't have the kind of focus on editing that has been going on for 40 years in environments like VIM and Emacs, right? Right. And, you know, I know I'm sounding like, I know how I'm sounding. I mean, there's something to be said, you know, people always say, learn your tools and it's going to serve you for a lifetime, right? Yeah, yeah.
如果你真的了解你的编辑器，嗯，关于 Emacs 的一点是它不仅仅是一个编辑器，对吧？它就像一个操作系统。它是一个环境。它之所以如此伟大，是因为你可以查看它的任何部分。你可以询问它关于它自己的事情。你不知道某件事是如何发生的。你可以问 Emacs，对吧？整个环境都为你开放，让你这样做。
If you really get to know your editor, well, the point about Emacs is it's more than an editor, right? It's like an operating system. It's an environment. What makes it so great is you can look at any part of it. You can ask it about itself. You don't know how something is happening. You can ask Emacs, right? The whole environment is open for you to do that.
而且你可以让它做任何他们想做的事情。对。所以如果你把这些和一些命令行能力结合起来，对吧？所以你知道 Git，你知道 CMake，你知道 grep、xargs、find，所有那些其他小的 POSIX 工具。你知道，不仅仅是 Emacs。它是，你知道，Emacs 比 VIM 更容易编程。但是，你知道，VIM 的强大之处在于它操作文本的语言，移动方式等等，对吧？
And you can make it do literally anything they want. Right. And so if you put that together with some command line mouse, right? So you know Git, you know, C-Make, you know, grep X-Args find, all those other small HOSIX utilities. You know, and it's not just E-Max. It's, you know, E-Max is a lot easier to program than VIM. But, you know, VIMs great string. is its language for manipulating text, the movements and such, right?
你可以让它做任何他们想做的事。没错。所以如果你把它和一些命令行工具结合起来，比如 Git、CMake、grep、xargs、find 以及所有那些小型 POSIX 工具。不仅仅是 Emacs，Emacs 的编程确实比 Vim 容易得多。但 Vim 的强大之处在于它操作文本的语言，比如移动光标等等，对吧？
And that can be implemented inside of Emacs. In fact, many people use evil mode. But I think among the camp of people who really sort of mold their environment around themselves, they already have a super nice workflow. You know, I've worked with people who are just wizards of that kind of thing. You know, you come to their desk, you ask them a question. Before you've even finished asking the question, they've been typing to find the answer, right, and not asking Google, but just doing some command line query, stringing together some Unix tools, and before you finish the question, literally they have the answer, right? You're asking about some, you know, some question about a data set that the company's working with. They can literally work at the speed of thought. Yeah, I mean
这可以在Emacs中实现。事实上，很多人使用evil模式。但我认为在那些真正围绕自己打造工作环境的人群中，他们已经拥有了非常棒的工作流。你知道，我曾与那些在这一领域堪称大师的人共事过。你知道，你走到他们的办公桌前问他们一个问题，还没等你问完，他们就已经在打字寻找答案了，不是去问谷歌，而是直接运行一些命令行查询，串联起一些Unix工具，在你问完问题之前，他们就已经得到了答案。你问的是关于公司正在处理的某个数据集的问题，他们真的可以达到思维同步的速度。是的，我的意思是
My thought This is going to sound I don't I don't mean this This is just the thought that popped into my head Is that is there analogy Because I definitely agree That learning your tools It serves you for life
我的想法是——这听起来可能……我不是那个意思，这只是我脑子里突然冒出的想法——有没有一种类比？因为我绝对同意，学习你的工具可以让你终身受益。
Like I completely agree with that sentiment And personally have experienced it Like I remember when I did my first kind of real co-op I worked at my university a couple summers but the first time I had a real internship during university
我完全同意这种观点，并且亲身经历过。我记得我第一次做真正的实习时，我在大学里做了几个暑假的工读，但那是我大学期间第一次真正的实习。
was at an insurance company in Canada called Manulife technically actually was at the subsidiary John Hancock which is an American company and actuaries use a lot of Excel and I remember standing behind my boss
是在加拿大一家叫宏利金融（Manulife）的保险公司，实际上是在其子公司约翰·汉考克（John Hancock），那是一家美国公司。精算师经常使用Excel，我记得我站在我老板身后，
at one point who was a young guy at the time so he was only a few years older than me And he was, like, moving around Excel like I had never seen before. Right. And I was like, what are you doing? And he was like, what do you mean? I was like, you just like went down to the bottom of the data in that column.
当时他还是个年轻人，只比我大几岁。他操作Excel的方式我从未见过。我问他在做什么，他说“什么意思？”我说，你刚才直接跳到了那一列数据的底部。
And he was like, uh, yeah. And I was like, how did you do that? And he was like, what are you talking about? Like, this is, this is like 101 Excel. Like, everyone knows this. But I was in school. I'd never seen anyone do this. And he's like, oh, you just hit control and use the arrow keys.
他说，“哦，是啊。”我说，“你是怎么做到的？”他说，“你在说什么？这只是Excel的基础操作，每个人都知道。”但我当时还在上学，从没见过有人这样做。他说，“哦，你只要按住Ctrl键再用方向键就行了。”
And if you want to select, you hit control shift. It blew my mind. It was like opening up Pandora's box. Anyways, the point being is over the next four months of that co-op term, I became like an Excel guru. And I remember in the interview process, they asked me on a scale of zero to ten, how are you in Excel? And I think I said nine or something, because I was like, ah, there's always room for improvement.
如果你想选中，就按Ctrl加Shift。这让我大开眼界，就像打开了潘多拉魔盒。总之，重点是，在接下来的四个月实习期里，我成了Excel高手。我记得在面试过程中，他们问我Excel水平从0到10分是多少，我想我说了9分左右，因为我觉得总有改进的空间。
I was a zero. I think I've told this story probably on the podcast at some point. I was a negative one. You know, I knew how to make a bar chart, and that was it. And I thought that's what Excel was for. But Excel is this massively powerful tool. The point being, I totally agree. with the sentiment,
我当时是0分。我想我可能在某个时候在播客里讲过这个故事。我当时是负1分。你知道，我只会做柱状图，仅此而已。我以为Excel就是用来做那个的。但Excel是一个功能极其强大的工具。重点是，我完全同意这个观点，
Emacs Vim, the folks that are, you know, that 1%, it's like magic watching people, people work, you know,
Emacs、Vim，那些属于那1%的人，看着他们工作简直就像魔法一样，你知道，
they never use their mouse. Yeah. It's fantastic. That being said, I do wonder, the thought that popped in my head is, the folks that are, you know,
他们从不使用鼠标。是的，太棒了。话虽如此，我确实在想，我脑子里冒出的想法是，那些，你知道，
doing the magic things, is it the equivalent of the person that was like the best at the abacus right before, you know, calculators came out. And like, calculators were the democratization
在做这些魔法般操作的人，他们是否等同于在计算器出现之前，那些最擅长使用算盘的人？而且，计算器是这些类型计算能力的民主化，
of the ability to do those types of calculations. You don't need to be an expert to use a calculator. And, you know, it did mean that folks that were experts at the abacus, did it, did it obsoleses? Is that a verb? Can you? What is the verb of, uh, yeah, I think that's right.
你不需要成为专家就能使用计算器。而且，这是否意味着那些算盘专家，他们被淘汰了？这是一个动词吗？你可以……淘汰这个词的动词形式是什么？是的，我想应该是这样。
Yeah, to obsoles that skill set. Anyways, that is, I don't mean it like, oh, if you've become an expert in this stuff, it's not important anymore. But at the same time, should it be that we're encouraging folks to, you know, become an expert in this vertical instead of saying, hey, there's this tool that, you know, don't need to become an expert in it. And if you watch the thinking or the reasoning of these models, they're doing all that stuff. They're grepping. They're using said. They're using Ock. Well, I think, I think why not both? You know, people should be experts in as many things
是的，淘汰那种技能组合。总之，我不是说如果你成为了这方面的专家，它就不再重要了。但与此同时，我们是否应该鼓励人们在这个垂直领域成为专家，而不是说，嘿，有这样一个工具，你不需要成为专家。如果你观察这些模型的思考或推理过程，它们正在做所有这些事情。它们在用grep，在用sed，在用awk。嗯，我认为，为什么不两者兼得呢？你知道，人们应该尽可能多地成为各个领域的专家，
as they can. You know, your brain is not a bucket to be filled where if you put too much things in, it pushes other things out. No, your brain is a tree where if you grow a new branch, you have more places to hang things. Oh, did you just come up with that on the spot? Or is that a quote from someone? That was brilliant. I don't know. I don't think it's an original thought.
你的大脑不是一个桶，装满了东西就会把其他东西挤出去。不，你的大脑是一棵树，如果你长出一根新树枝，你就有更多的地方可以挂东西。哦，你是当场想出这个比喻的吗？还是引用别人的话？这太精彩了。我不知道。我不认为这是一个原创的想法。
I wasn't quoting anyone. But that's how to look at it, right? Right. Because that's how knowledge is. It's associative in nature. We don't forget one thing because we learn a new thing. No, we relate new things to the things we already know. and our whole knowledge tree grows.
我不是在引用任何人。但这就是看待它的方式，对吧？没错。因为知识就是这样，本质上是联想性的。我们不会因为学习了新东西而忘记旧东西。不，我们将新事物与我们已经知道的事物联系起来，我们的整个知识树就会成长。
Yeah, I mean, I don't, that's a fantastic sentiment. And I don't disagree. Yeah, I'm curious to see what will happen. Like I said, my evolving view is that there's a set of things, and I think what's going to end up happening, though, is that for the non-experts, they are going to veer more towards this kind of AI-assisted code writing,
是的，我的意思是，这是一个非常棒的观点。我并不反对。是的，我很好奇会发生什么。就像我说的，我不断演变的观点是，有一系列的事情，我认为最终会发生的是，对于非专家来说，他们会更多地转向这种人工智能辅助的代码编写，
and then there's going to be not a bifurcation necessarily maybe it'll always be some kind of sliding scale but for the folks like you and maybe this is a good transition point to your C++ now talk that is not public
然后不会出现必然的分叉，也许它总会是一个滑动比例，但对于像你这样的人来说——也许这是一个很好的过渡点，谈谈你现在那个尚未公开的C++演讲，
are we allowed to link it to the listeners if they're listening? It's fine well it's unlisted at the moment. It's unlisted but guess what if you're a listener we'll link it in the show notes but yes I mean you are showing
我们能把它链接给听众吗？如果他们正在听的话？没关系，它目前是不公开的。它是不公开的，但猜猜怎么着，如果你是听众，我们会把它放在节目说明里，但是的，我的意思是，你正在展示
I would say some pretty sophisticated stuff in your talk, especially at the end there, where you had the whole, the bonus slides, where you had the whole, that was just the, yeah, that's just something silly. But the point being is that I do think there's going to be kind of like this bucket of experts where expertise is really required. That being said, there will be a percentage or fraction of the work that is definitely outsourced to these LLMs. Be sure to check these show notes.
我在你的演讲中看到了非常复杂的内容，特别是在最后，你有那些奖励幻灯片，那只是……是的，那只是些愚蠢的东西。但重点是，我确实认为会存在一个专家群体，在那里专业知识确实是必需的。话虽如此，肯定会有一定比例的工作被外包给这些大语言模型。一定要查看这些节目说明。
in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti-brace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在你的播客应用中或访问ADSPthepodcast.com获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有愉快的一天。我是反括号派。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。